[Music]
excuse me I was just enjoying my
favorite youtuber Johnny D absolute
legend my god look at him nothing like a
senior rapping some lil yachty karaoke
while your grandson is screaming in the
background quality content this is the
kind of content I can only dream about
creating you know when you go to your
favorite gaming journalists website and
you want to know what's up about the
latest game but then you scroll down and
there's all these like weird click beta
articles
well as it turns out I have had the
honor of becoming immortalized as
clickbait thank you God thank you seven
times
you're a toxic gamer yes I made it as
clickbait finally it's a 2012 PT 5 but
whatever click good enough good enough
even made it to the print of gaming
former I like how they had this one call
me the ugly is this the good then the
good and the ugly it's a turn bad fasted
in it but here I am and I wanted to
investigate what the seven signs of
being a toxic gamer are because who
knows maybe you are a toxic gamer
yourself like yours truly found the
article let's investigate toxic gaming
is something we hear about over and over
again the phrase itself has lost a bit
of its punch that's called a that's a
nice throwback to the thumbnail of there
this is well written I'm sure that was
intentional some online gaming
communities have suffered from an
overarching nasty environment you ever
notice how like the most toxic games are
the ones that are the most annoying to
play here's a look at some of the things
we should avoid doing when playing
online to make gaming more enjoyable for
everyone let's watch extreme cursing if
you swear while playing video games well
I got news for you buddy
you're toxic
when you start directing these swear
words that other people in a negative
way then it's not okay okay they've gone
too far
and it well in the whole n-word Fiasco
thing I didn't say it to anyone so many
people were confused about it like I
just said it to myself and Brad so
according to topics and seven signs I
wasn't actually being toxic because I
was just saying it to myself but
whatever anyone who has ever had someone
say fu to them directly knows what I'm
talking about the pain I remember the
first time anyone said vf4 directly to
me crime or they literally just crime or
someone said [ __ ] you to you what are
you gonna do I mean Kristen Channel
someone said FID linked to you what are
you gonna do it doesn't feel very nice
all right moving on we have six more I
like how they have seven for some reason
I don't know how they came up with that
number
there's just seven of them that's that's
all you got insulting other players
mothers that's stepping about my mother
and I will be very angry and I might
even cuss at you and I'm a Christian
Channel
so you better watch it I have never
understand why people get offended by
saying your mama laughs I fiddled your
mama no you didn't I know for a fact
that you didn't because I have a webcam
in a room no but some dumb will you say
but my mother how do you get triggered
by that I think people need to say it
more now so that people get over it my
god maybe I'm a psychopath
you know maybe that's the case but I
just don't understand how people get so
offended by words it's really I can't
comprehend it if people say they are I'm
not gonna push it it's more like
personally I don't understand it you
know that meme you know what I'm talking
to you now yeah
most everyone can let these come and
slide off their back and some
I'd even find them funny if someone does
say they are offended then drop the
jokes it's not hard it's not hard to
drop jokes guys
whining first two items on our list
definitely contribute to negative online
communities the following items are so
much more of a problem okay you know
what I can kind of agree with this one
there's always that player that thinks
he's better than everyone else and if
people aren't performing to his standard
even though he's not probably doing that
great either it's always like oh oh
number four camping if you camp in a
video game which literally everyone has
done at least once in their life you are
toxic oh my gosh if there's one thing
that annoys me personally more than
anything else in the list it's camping
it's just lazy gaming you can't sit in
an adventure spot the entire match game
or you could rely on your skills most
everyone can take advantage of a spawn
point but the real talent lies in those
that can use a whole map effectively
this sounds like is written by someone
really a latticed about games like you
sit in the corner playing you foul
player you just sit and Connor me
experience effective player I use whole
map to distribute my skills I go over
here I go over here and I would never I
would never sit in one place for too
long cuz I'm not a camper no no no
because that's toxic why pop G is
literally all about advancing to the
better positions and then rinse and
repeat you know that's the point of the
game so that you are in the circle and
have the best spot in the circle if
people cam too much in the game then
that's the game's fault and if people
want to camp [ __ ] that than camp
literally crime or boosting there's a
huge difference between playing a game I
live with friends and outright boosting
if you and a friend are entering a match
and sitting in the corner of each other
you are making the experience less fun
for everyone
oh yeah they this was the thing in Call
of Duty do people still do that
it's literally
to people placing that's those tactical
stocks or whatever and then just killing
each other so they can respawn next to
each other and then win the game when I
play modern warfare 2 I never ever had a
problem with boosters because it's so
easy to find them and literally you just
get two free kills yes seriously oh I
see the problem here is that they don't
know how to utilize the entire map and
find the boost s it's impossible maybe
if you are an effective player and non
toxic player like me then you could find
these boosters I'm surprised cheating
hasn't come up to be honest hey boy it's
your boy there's something that really
just need to be said on any occasion the
entirety of this list relates to that
most golden of rules if you don't have
something nice to say then don't say
anything at all there are many words and
phrases in the world that are absolutely
unacceptable if you're seeing anything
that personally attacks someone for the
race gender sexual preference you should
take a hard look at yourself there's no
reason to be attacking people when you
well I wasn't talking to the guy
directly okay can we get that clear
it can be hard sometimes for people to
remember it's just a game it's just a
game they're meant to have fun while
they can get competitive it doesn't have
to be abusive well I mean I agree okay I
would never call someone directly to be
fair like I was wrong for letting it
slip out and I was wrong for saying
there were no doubt but you play games
to let off steam I really really don't
see any problem with toxicity I think
people put way too much emphasis on it
being such a horrible thing for people
playing online literally just mute just
mute the whole game it's not that hard
what do you want to do talk to people
hello fellow friend let's go kill some
enemies like there are other types of
games where I'm sure you can have a good
time you know just chill being toxic
online it's it's part of the game a lot
of times is used as a tactic so just
take the other players off and it's fun
it's fun because you're not allowed to
be like that anywhere else it's sort of
like part of the game and everyone who
plays the game knows that that's is how
you act online
and it's a difference literally the only
thing I find annoying online is these
people with the mic just either playing
music or like screaming into the
microphone and just doing a bunch of
weird annoying noises like that's
annoying but banning people for being
toxic is so stupid some of my favorite
games growing up was tibia and World of
Warcraft and those had a huge online
community people talking to each other
and that was some of the most fun I ever
had in a game tibia especially was such
a game where you could be the most toxic
you could be and I think it's such a
great outlet for kids instead of doing I
don't know stuff in the real world how
hurting people doing illegal stuff you
know I did so much horrible [ __ ] I did
so much horrible stuff in tibia like
blank Tinley stealing lying manipulating
like as a kid I was horrible but I had a
place to be horrible in a video game
where it's safe to be and I think
banning that kind of behavior it's just
it does no good it's part of the game
and it's part of what makes the game fun
I have so many funny memories of these
things and literally I got the same
treatment from other people as well in
it it's like it makes you toughen up and
they makes you realize these are just
words it's just part of the game no one
actually cares go ahead and be toxic
I give you my seal of approval it's
gonna piss people off that I said all
this but it's what I believe a plus amen
Christian channel I couldn't find
another word to rams with Eamonn really
Ben